THIS SATURDAY, INSIDE CAPITAL
ONE, WITH THE CAPITALS ON TOP
PUTTING A LITTLE FROWN ON N OPP
SPIN AROUND BY McMcM, BUT THE R
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE ARE
SETTING IN FOR HIM.  PROTAS,
ANOTHER BIG REBOUND OFF THE
PAST, RIGHT THERE, HE DOESN'T
PUT IT  PROPERLY INTO THE
CORNER, THE : SEAN KURALY DIDN'T
GET THE CL
ALEX OVECHKIN AND JENNER. FORE
TONIGHT, WITH HAGELI.
AS CARLSON LOOKS TO CONNECT THE
T THE FAR
SIDE OF THE GOALTENDERE
OFFSIDE.NOT.
HOFFMAN HAD THE PUCK, BUT WATCH
WHERE HOFFMAN IS, WAY
DMITRY ORLOV WITH THE CHECK,
TH
OVERALL FROM THE BACK END.
SHEARY THERE ATOTHE GAME, IT IS
CERTAINLY APPARENT.
HE WAS AE, AS HE PUT A GOALIE
STIC. CARLSON,
AT THAT POINT POSITION,
MANAGING TO KEEP IT IN I
STATIONED AT CENTER,SECOND TIMEE
GAME HE HAS DONE THAT.
LOOK ASILLINGER
THAT GOES THE OTHER WAY FO
FOR HATHAWAY TO WORK THE GIVE
.
HATHAWAY TO THE
HIM TO SET UP, PERHAPS
FRUSTRATION FROM COLUMBUS, NOT
ALLEY-OOP, HE IS
PLAYING ALONG WITHWILL IN TIME.
TURNING AWAY HERE, HATHAWAY, HOE
VICTORY, AND THE ROTATION
OUTSIDE BY